rachid ferrache vous étiez le petit
simon dans l'as des as donc vous avez
joué avec jean paul belmondo avant de
d'évoquer ce souvenir pour vous en
regardez quelques images
[Applaudissements]
mazel bellecour gaby
héberge auriez-vous pour la nuit un
orphelin sont des fausses
bien sûr bonsoir madame ça tu vas dormir
chez michelot d'état l'état allait
débrouille toi
c'est pour la bonne cause
vous avez tourné un âge très tendre avec
une immense vedette quel est le souvenir
que vous gardez le principal souvenir
j'imagine que vous en avez cent mille le
principal souvenir c'est je crois que
c'est quand même quand jean-paul quand
je fais le dernier avant le tournage
avant le tournage quand je fais des
derniers castings que le dernier casting
c'est avec jean-paul dans les bureaux de
la gaumont à charles à neuilly avenue
charles de gaulle et l'avenue charles de
gaulle et et qui discute un peu avec moi
comme ça il en train de voir ce que je
donne si je dis aux répondants s'ils si
je suis pas trop timide et et à la fin
il me dit bon je crois qu'il va partir
avec nous et en fait c'est quand on a 10
ans et qu'on est fan de belmondo c'est
quelque chose qui se passe de très
particulier c'est que on va tourner avec
son idole mais ce qui est paradoxal
c'est que j'ai pas la notion de tournage
je sais pas ce que c'est qu'un tournage
pour moi je vais juste être avec
belmondo pendant quatre mois à m'éclater
avec lui j'en ai absolument s'est
tournée commencée payer quoi que ce soit
ça m'intéresse pas déjà je vais partir
son départ en quatre mois en allemagne
je vais peut aller à l'école pendant
trois mois ça c'est pas mal aussi à
l'époque
c'est que du bon enfin c'est quand
j'aurai des cours quand même tous les
jours mais un jeu mais voilà mais voilà
c'est fantastique après les autres
souvenirs sont hors tournage j'ai un
souvenir qui est mémorable quand il me
dit tu as envie de conduire ferrari
et ouais c'est de mieux en mieux
je dis ouais et là il me fous sur ses
genoux de la ferrari et on part sur
l'autoroute il en est à 200 km/heure et
me dit tu tiens le volant sur le volant
je suis sur ses genoux bien entendu est
sécurisé mais ne fait croire que je
conduis la voiture à 200 km h sur
l'autoroute fantastique cdc des moments
comme ça que sont incroyables et puis
tout le moment à côté ou où il me
faisait répéter alors que c'était pas
son rôle il m'a appris tout les termes
du cinéma et puis il était très très
protecteur très protecteur et puis on
s'amusait beaucoup m'apprenait
d'ailleurs il m'apprenait les premiers
rudiments de la boxe voilà les skis la
totale fantastique et je voulais revenir
sur une anecdote parce que vous avez
couru de là c'est grave danger paraît-il
pendant ce tournage vous et jean paul
belmondo lors d'une scène de poursuite
avant que nous en parler on va regarder
la scène de france 8 ans et ensuite vous
allez nous en parler
en valeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la scène est impressionnante et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
pendant cette semaine alors en fait pour
je conduise le véhicule rémy julienne le
cascadeur est installé on le voit pas
parce qu'il est de l'autre côté de la
voiture sur une plateforme qui est fixée
le long du marchepied avec un siège un
volant des pédales et tout un mécanisme
qui est relié à mécanique de la voiture
quand jean-paul se lève avant de se
lever il actionne une manette qui donne
le compte le contrôle à rémy julienne
d'accord sauf que il donne le contrôle
en se relevant pour passer sur le capot
pour sortir la voiture est ré accroche
la manette et désactive le contrôle de
rémy julienne je me retrouve à conduire
une voiture qui fait 2 tonnes à 80
km/heure à côté des routes sinueuses la
flore avant à côté et en fait moi je
m'en aperçois pas je suis dans mon auto
tamponneuses c'est à dire que je fais un
travail sur la voiture je me sens total
chantant de conduire je m'en aperçois
pas jusqu'au moment où rémy julienne se
détache donc du siège et revient dans la
voiture ça a pris 20 secondes mais on
était à 80 km/heure jean paul était en
train de passer sur le capot sur ce
moment là on voit passer dans l'extrême
il était il est allongé sur le capot et
à gérard oury qui est ficelé avec une
sangle sur une aile et l'opérateur
caméra qui est allongée à crochets qui
ne semble pas dire qu'ils ne peuvent
même pas agir eux jean-paul s'en
aperçoit pas lui croit que c'est rémy
julienne qui conduit et en fait non
c'était moi mais ça a duré vingt
secondes on a failli finir dans le fossé
c'est irène j'aurais dû monter une
auto-école français